Welcome to today's lecture on data structures and algorithms.
We'll begin by discussing linear algebra fundamentals, specifically matrices and vectors.
A matrix is a rectangular array of numbers arranged in rows and columns.
The determinant of a matrix is a scalar value that can be computed from its elements.
Moving on to calculus, let's discuss differentiation and the chain rule.
The derivative measures the rate of change of a function with respect to its variable.
In probability theory, we work with random variables and probability distributions.
The expectation or expected value is the average outcome of a random variable.
For algorithm analysis, we use Big-O notation to describe computational complexity.
Dynamic programming is a technique for solving complex problems by breaking them down.